i'm
dawn zamaro and i'm pleased to start off
our presentation on
an approach to skill mapping and online
courses i'm here with my colleagues uh
directly to my left ross straiter also
from stanford university and norman beer
from carnegie mellon university and we
are all members of the open learning
initiative it is actually instantiated
at both carnegie mellon and stanford
university
and some of you may have heard in 2002
the open learning initiative started
with a grant from the hewlett foundation
to build
openly accessible online courses that
targeted the introductory college level
courses
and we have evolved over the last 12
plus years and we're going to talk about
a major design principle in the open
learning initiative courses today
and we are only keeping this to 15 or 20
minutes so that we can engage you in
discussion if you don't ask us questions
we have some questions to prompt you in
discussions at the end and i'll help
facilitate that
and so we actually do have to keep it to
15 to 20 minutes because uh two of us
work directly with candace till and so
uh we'll hear about it if it goes over
so
we're doing a bit of a round robin today
uh don gave you a little bit of a quick
background on oli um i just wanted to uh
talk about uh a quick agenda and then
i'll turn it over to norm
uh norm we'll talk about uh the skills
map process that we used uh in oli and
actually show off the uh the dashboard
that that gets you that's kind of the
uh the prize you get for doing the hard
work of attacking things with learning
objectives and skills uh then we'll talk
about uh some of our next steps you know
there's some uh lots of lessons learned
in oli over the the last 12 years and uh
where we're going to take those uh going
forward
and then dawn's actually going to talk
about some of the implications for uh
for this around student learning she has
a a
strong background in assessment and so
can can speak to that for us and then
like i said we'll keep that uh hopefully
short and and open it up for discussion
but i tell you 15 minutes seems like an
eternity after the three minute talks in
the lightning round session so we we
have it easy
so before we dive into the slide deck i
actually wanted to give you a quick demo
um
how many of you have seen an oli course
in the past little quick few hands
fantastic and how many of you have seen
or at least heard of the learning
dashboard that's inside of oli smaller
number all right so when we talk about
the skills mapping process we do skills
mapping for a number of reasons but one
of them the one that seems to be most
popular particularly for folks that are
instructing
well that's a terrible demo
within 45 minutes of discussions if you
guys have questions or thoughts along
the way please feel free to stop and
interject
it was working when i tested it about a
minute and a half ago
no guesses we can jump back to the power
point it's the uh
yeah i can um
so what you're looking at in this case
is an image of the olei learning
dashboard static and not quite as
exciting as a live demo but it's uh what
you're going to get current technology
the notion here is that sitting
underneath every oli course
we have an underlying cognitive model
that's going to capture
what we think of as estimating student
learning so students are moving through
sets of activities inside of oli we want
to make some predictions about how well
they have mastered an underlying set of
skills and on top of that how well
they've mastered student-centered
measurable learning outcomes what this
gets us from a faculty perspective is
the ability to take a quick look and see
where students are struggling based on
this model where they think they're
going to be succeeding and from that
drive where should i be spending my time
inside of the classroom so this is a
little bit different from simply looking
at scores of quizzes which are often
considered as proxies for learning
instead we really want to drill in to
see where are we estimating high levels
of learning
getting there requires a lot of work and
most of our learning engineers and
course developers will tell you that
this isn't just a lot of work it's a
painful amount of work
the underlying model for this is built
off of some of the research from marsha
lovett
at carnegie mellon and
what we're doing is starting off with a
set of learning objectives these are the
underlying principles for every oli
course this is how we get started when
we begin doing design
we want to break these learning
objectives down into a set of skills and
this tends to be a pretty pragmatic
process this is one of the things that
both our course authors and our learning
engineers will often struggle with
because we have a natural tendency to be
reductionist we want to keep on breaking
things down into smaller and smaller
component parts
but core to this notion of breaking
things down into smaller pieces from our
perspective is what is going to be
useful to someone that's teaching what's
going to be useful in the classroom and
if we start breaking things down to a
level where it's no longer actionable to
an instructor then we've probably broken
these pieces down too far
from these skills then we're going to
relate the skills to the individual
activities that compose an oli course
the way that we currently do this is
through a set of spreadsheets which is
not particularly high tech or
sophisticated
but which manages to get the job done we
don't have a single set of processes for
getting here
we've got a number of courses that we've
ended up retrofitting with skills maps
what we're trying to do now for all of
our new courses is embed this in the
design process
once you have a skills map we're able to
take advantage of a couple different
pieces of technology and
one of the ones that's probably most
important from my perspective is data
shop which is a data analysis tool from
the pittsburgh science of learning
center
once we've actually had some students
work through our courses what we're able
to do is uh use datashop to analyze the
validity of our underlying model so if
this isn't a useful model or more likely
if there are places where we've mixed up
some skills conflated some learning
objectives we have a set of tools that
exist inside of data shop that can give
us some advanced warning about this
often what we'll be able to do is go in
and de-tangle these different kinds of
activities at other points if we're not
able to detangle them what it tells us
is we may not have the correct set of
activities for what we're attempting to
teach the student
this in turn plugs into the underlying
skills map this is what's labeled as the
theoretic model
and we've got two pieces at work here we
start off with what we think of as a
naive model before we actually have data
and what we're going to capture with our
naive model is not just the relationship
between the activities and the learning
objectives but also some parameters
about knowledge acquisition prior
learning and difficulty to attain the
skills
once we have some additional data we're
able to fine-tune this model and so this
is a proprietary process that
works through the model gives us a
little bit of tuning
as students work through the course then
we have a
bayesian statistical model that's going
to make predictions about their learning
using these underlying sets of
parameters what that gets us
is the dashboard but it also gives us a
set of tools that we're able to use for
ongoing course improvement
turn it over to you
so like i said when i started off uh in
in 12 years at uh at oli uh we tried a
lot of things we had some successes and
we had some experiments that didn't work
out so well and i think one of the
themes of this workshop is talking about
you know what worked what didn't work
we're kind of all experimenting here and
then seeing how best to move forward
i think one of the successes we had is
that all of the course content all of
our courses that we had are openly and
freely licensed through creative commons
however the processes and tools for
creating those courses were not and that
really limited adoption we had a lot of
people you know coming to us and saying
ah i get it i see where you guys are
coming from and learning science is
wrapped up in these courses and these
are great how can i build one
and the unfortunate answer was that you
couldn't and so one of the things that
we're trying to do is open this up in a
number of ways so don mentioned that lli
has now expanded from carnegie mellon to
stanford is at both universities now
we're looking at delivering online
courses on other platforms
currently the one that we think is uh
is closest to being able to deliver oli
courses is open edx and so a big part of
our work at stanford is building in some
of the features into that platform
necessary to support oli style courses
and then also in terms of the tools and
processes that that norm spoke about
you know he mentioned that the skills
map process was a little bit painful
in the first round so trying to create
tools that make that process a little
bit better
and
one of the things there is to tie it
more closely to the content
he mentioned that we had everything in
these spreadsheets which worked but
being able to
as a an instructor author's content to
be able to tag that content those
questions with the skills and learning
objectives right there in the authoring
environment would uh would be a big step
forward
as well as to do that so that's not tied
to a specific platform you know ideally
you could imagine that regardless of one
environment that you're in you'd be able
to tag
activities with these with this metadata
and it wouldn't be uh it wouldn't be one
process there'd be a lot of flexibility
there
the other is the analytics you know so
the analytics that norm mentioned again
were tied very closely to the oli
platform
but we're imagining those as a bigger
service outside of the platform that
could then allow us to collect data
across courses and hopefully even across
platforms and
schools
as well
to test out some of these learning
models
one of the other pieces is the learning
model itself which was hard coded into
the platform at oli but
having that be pluggable would be really
interesting to be able to test out
different models and compare them
against each other
and finally the results of the model the
data visualizations
you know we had some that
we took a good stab at and then got some
good results but i think there's plenty
of other ways to go about this as well
lots of research and improvement to be
made on data visualizations
what kinds of data best help instructors
you know what do you want to see right
before you go into class about what your
students have learned in the online
environment
the night before
when we talk about students what kind of
daily data visualizations are
appropriate there or maybe it's not even
a data visualization you know one of the
things that
i think is really powerful here is is
once we have this this model of the
student's knowledge state running in the
background
you know that can be used to deliver
adaptive learning but maybe even in a
better way than we've imagined it so far
usually when people talk about adaptive
learning it's it's sort of we know what
the student needs to do next and we're
going to deliver that to them in a very
linear fashion
which is great i mean that'd be a step
forward from a lot of
a lot of what we have now
but in some sense that does a disservice
to the student right because we're not
helping them to develop those
metacognitive skills to to be able to
decide for themselves what they need to
do next
so you can imagine
using this model and the predictions
from this model to actually tutor the
student on whether or not they need more
help and we know that
students who are underperforming will
often overestimate their abilities
so if we ask them you know okay you've
worked through you know five activities
on uh constructing a box plot
are you ready to move on student may say
yeah i think i got it and really the
data showed that no you need more
practice so helping them develop those
metacognitive skills would help them not
just in the statistics course but then
in in all their courses uh you know
online or traditional
and then finally tools for
instructors and researchers uh
especially we have some uh
some first cuts at that norm mentioned
the data shop which has been a valuable
tool but it's still kind of hard to get
at the data so making those data
accessible to these people with with
very different needs we think is another
way to open things up
i'll leave last three minutes for dawn
so we're attending a conference learning
with moocs and we've mentioned the open
learning initiative courses and i should
have mentioned the beginning we actually
have two flavors of courses that uh
learners can take one is what we call
our open and free courses they're
asynchronous and they're not facilitated
so any learner can go into the
oli.cmu.edu website and access
the inventory of courses on their own go
through as a self-paced
modules and they get all the activities
they don't get end of modules quizzes or
sometimes called checkpoints
and then the second flavor of an open
learning initiative course is a
facilitated course that's closed to a
cohort of students so an instructor may
want to use the probability and
statistics course in
um in their community college and they
are able to make an instance of that
course have their students sign up and
facilitate that and
sometimes those courses are taught
completely online we have some
instructors who teach global students
across the world and but what we see is
a lot of our instructors are using that
in the hybrid or flipped format as a
supplement to what's happening in the
classroom so you've probably heard some
discussion about that
and so in terms of why did we want to
make a presentation about the skills
mapping process and our design process
at the open learning initiative this is
the so what slide what do we think are
the implications for student learning
and where moocs and other online courses
can evolve moving forward
so one is about the design process
itself so as norm mentioned it can be a
painful process for our course designers
our learning engineers and our
instructors to sit down together and
really think through the domain and what
are the learning objectives and the
skills
contained in that domain sometimes we've
retrofitted those courses but moving
forward we're trying to really have that
conversation up front
and also as a part of the open learning
initiative we really look at this as a
community designed research project and
so this is rarely one instructor
building his or her online course this
is a community of instructors and
content experts often across multiple
institutions thinking through
what would an introductory psychology
course look like and then having
discussions about what the domain looks
like and learning objectives
and then
as an assessment person okay if these
are our learning objectives and skills
how are we going to create the
activities and the assessments to really
measure those and build that in an
online environment so that students are
getting
practice as we've seen a couple of
presentations today about the importance
of practice and then also embedded in
the design as targeted feedback so when
students make a response to all the
activities i should say most of the
activities in an open learning
initiative course they get immediate
feedback both in a formative
mechanism when they're practicing the
problems throughout the course and if
they're in a facilitated course they
also take summative assessments that can
give them feedback about the correctness
and identify misconceptions if they get
the correct
the question wrong
in addition to the design process
real-time data is shared with
instructors and students and ross
mentioned
where we might think this might head in
terms of being able to problem students
about where they need additional
practice but also providing instructors
particularly those that are using this
in a hybrid format to say i want my
students to work through the first
module i can look at that dashboard that
norm presented see where my students are
struggling and then either re-instruct
or do some instructional intervention
just in time teaching based on real-time
data of the learning objectives students
are and are not getting
we also
think that the open learning initiative
has really pushed the envelope in terms
of measuring direct student learning
outcomes versus proxies for learning so
we're not looking at how much time
students are spending uh engaged in
looking at a video we're actually
measuring direct performance
related to activities and assessments
that are aligned with learning outcomes
and so we're getting those direct
measures and we're modeling those
behaviors so if students are getting
five questions in a row correct have we
predicted that they have mastered that
learning objective and then providing
students and instructors data about that
and
norm also mentioned this is we're doing
iterative improvement so after a course
has been delivered or sequences
multiple instances of the course are
delivered we're able to tell the course
designers what's working and what's not
working so did we have the wrong skills
map to start with or maybe the
assessments were off we didn't ask the
questions in the right way or we need to
group them differently and so we're able
to
not just create a course and have it be
static for every time we deliver it
we're able to improve upon
the activities and assessments and
overall design
and activities embedded in that course
and we've actually written a white paper
describing the current oli skills
mapping process if anyone is interested
in seeing that there's a url where you
can access that white paper
so that concludes the formal part of our
conversation
and presentation about our skills
mapping process there's a mic that we
can pass around for you to ask questions
and then as i said if you don't have
questions we'll ask you some
yes so so my question
is
is based on uh novice expert literature
to some extent
uh and it
addresses a fundamental point uh that
may not be so much of a problem in a
highly procedural uh course like uh oli
but it's more of a problem for us in
physics where it isn't so clear exactly
which method you use to solve the
problem and it's the following
in general these skill models are based
on an expert perception of the course
an expert's perception yet we are
teaching
novices and so it might turn out i mean
we would be of course
obviously remiss if we put a lot some of
the questions in italian
okay we know that the students would
fail those and it wouldn't be because
they didn't know the the stuff we think
or the skills but if we use a highly
technical phrase
and their novices the same thing might
happen okay
or it might be that we assume that
students know how to read graphs
but in fact they don't know how to read
graphs or some of them i mean i was
amazed that mit students
improve on graph conceptual conceptual
problems and graphs as much from the
second semester
from the end of the first semester of
freshman year
to
when they graduate as they learned in
freshman year when they were taking
intro physics and intro calculus
so
my question is
after that long preamble uh my question
is how does your does your data
analytics is it powerful enough
to look for other
similarities like some sort of
multi-dimensional analysis outside of if
you're if your expert
skill model is wrong
and other things are important is it
going to detect that and is going to
help you identify them and if so how
so it's a great and very perceptive
question um
and so there are two pieces to this and
the first is this recognition that when
we first launch a course and we have
what i referred to as a naive model and
the reality is that it is exceptionally
naive
and and so these are places where the
initial piloting set of faculty need to
be told very clearly that what we're
working with is our best guess and that
it tends to be
very susceptible to the kind of expert
blind spot that you're outlining
once we've had some students begin to
work through the course and we've got
some real data to consider this is where
the data shop tools come in and are
incredibly useful and powerful in
detecting these places where from an
expert's opinion i've grouped together a
like set of activities but when we drill
into the data what we're finding is that
no i'm asking students to do two or
three things at the same time
we've got a
i i do have a slide for this how many of
you have worked with uh learning curves
in uh data shop utility
right zach you want to explain it
uh so from what i understand uh learning
curve analysis looks at a particular
learning objective or as called
knowledge component and then looks at
over the opportunities to answer
a question of that knowledge component
how does performance change in the
aggregate
so you would expect percent correct to
go up you would expect error which i
believe this is to go down you'd expect
response time fluency
to increase
and to the extent that this curve
doesn't look very smooth you may have
erroneous imperfect
mapping of a knowledge component to the
items that are associated with that
knowledge component so you might need to
separate out
items or you might have two knowledge
components represented there so i think
learning curve analysis tries to find a
smooth curve by merging and adding
skills to the mix
it was really good although i'm
horrified what do you mean this isn't a
smooth curve man this is perfect this is
a beautiful learning curve as as
opportunities increase the amount of
assistance that students need decreases
this is learning happening in action
normally the first time that we build a
skill model we don't get curves that
look like this i mean this is the result
of lots of tweaking both of the model
and of the inner instructional
activities more often we'll get things
like this
and as soon as you see this what you
want to need to dig into is what are the
activities that are causing this what
are my underlying assumptions uh and so
this is really the place where we're
able to go in and identify some of these
spots where
expert misconception expert blind spot
or conflation have occurred
so one of the
weaknesses of the learning curve is it
doesn't tell me exactly what the
underlying reason is what this now
requires me to do is to drill into my
course or my set of instructional
activities and come up with a hypothesis
and so that could be a reasonable one
um
the underlying analytics allow for both
uh students that might move around and
encounter knowledge components in
different sequences and for the fact
that a student can bounce around and as
in locked into an individual path so
this is there are a number of
explanations and one of the things
model is decay over time so students
forgetting a concept as they move on
most of the courage that we had
were for activities that were fairly
closely grouped in time and so typically
in that sort of strain scenario when we
saw something like this it really hits
at the point you were raising that as
expert designers we conflated some
things and so there's actually multiple
skills here that we haven't broken out
enough because we're missing that that
nama's point of view and so going back
and look at those activities and what
skills really are represented there uh
helps us to straighten those out
and that's the other important point on
this is there are other ways to try to
account for this
one of them is that when we talk about
team-based design one of the most
important roles in this we refer to it
as a learning engineer but we may just
as well refer to this as an expert
learner someone that is not a domain
expert and so is there to say hey you've
just skipped a step i don't understand
what what's just happened as you're
explaining these concepts
different organizations are dealing with
this in different ways
my understanding is that kaplan at this
point has completely done away with the
domain expert when they begin doing
their skills mapping because they feel
like
that level of expertise isn't helpful
we feel when we're building our design
teams that know that expertise continues
to be pretty important but we want to
have other expertise to support it
harvard number of opportunities or is
each opportunity consistently labeled
like does every single student go
through opportunities 1 through 16 in
the same order or they just sort of 16
things that they did
16 things that they did and in fact
you would need to drill into this a
little further to find the point when
most of your students have stopped
proceeding through the activities this
doesn't imply that every student in my
data set has done all
opportunities
so typically when i design a course
if i
the the process of giving us sort of for
example 50 multiplication problems i do
it at elementary school level
beyond that i tend to give students
problems at increasing difficulty so i
try to make sure that the failure rate
is fairly cons
and problems fairly constant as opposed
to decreasing
and
in many cases i do projects with tests
for example not one skill component but
100 skill components or if i'm testing
some doing something like humanities
and i have a simple question it might
have to stop sort of the things
transfer book how do you how specific
how discipline specific is this or how
do you handle
other pedagogies other uh
disciplines
so we've done it in a number of
different disciplines and i'm not going
to claim that it works
perfectly everywhere
but so far we haven't found a discipline
that we haven't been able to apply the
underlying design process but you're
correct in that it does assume that
you're building out a sequence of
step-by-step activities and that if
we're going to be asking students to do
something more difficult then the
implication there is that this is a in
some ways a different skill or a
different learning outcome that we're
attempting to teach them or attempting
to assess them on and so in some ways we
need to tease out what's happening at
those different difficulty levels versus
what the initial
skills are so so i guess if you were for
example look at this instead of learning
curves where all the problems are of a
similar in some sense of a similar
difficulty get that decline an
alternative model that's used out of uh
computer testing is i basically just
have a server optimization that
optimizes problem difficulty until it's
constant and i get a nice smooth flat
curve with for example 80 success rate
uh could you compare the two a little
bit
uh no
so are you asking about whether or not
all these assessment activities are
parallel test items and of the same
difficulty level or if they increase in
complexity over the course if they were
to increase in complexity over the 40
items i would expect that curve not to
decline like that
i would in fact if i were resign a
learning activity as a human tutor i try
to make sure the student gets most of
the things but not everything correct
and absorbs difficulty appropriately so
that sort of declining curve is
in some sense something i'm a little bit
concerned about
if that makes sense
so um one of the areas in which i think
our design process could significantly
improve is actually in creating those
interactive activities and the
assessment questions right so there's
the balance between am i creating 40
unique opportunities on the same skill
right so in some of our disciplines
calculate the mean if i gave 40
different problems with new different
numeric parameters that's an easy
learning curve analysis to do right
because the skill is pretty clear and
students have just done it 40 times in
conversation with some of our faculty
members saying well my skills build on
upon one another or conceptually the
course gets more difficult and so while
calculate the mean may be step one and
unit one by the time i'm um in this the
tenth module that's a skill embedded in
that learning objective but the problem
actually has ten different skills in it
and what we see happen there is the
learning curves actually bounce up and
down
and i don't think i actually want
problems in my course
that's true
you can't move on beyond that but in
most cases to structure that design
where i start with
a really simple campaign for me if so to
get it i give them a more advanced one
if they get that and i give them one
with less scaffolding where they do it
in the comics of the word problem if
they don't get it i simplify it as a
very different pedagogical design
process and and so
that's the challenge that i think we
need to figure out is how many practice
opportunities do you need to give
students of the same kind of problem or
if they're increasing in complexity then
you're not going to get great learning
curves but what does that mean actually
to predict their learning in in more
complex ways
you may not be breaking you may not be
thinking of skills as fine grain enough
so as problem complexity increases
typically we've broken things down so
that we're adding more skills
because you're right if like take those
two learning curves that i've drawn on
the left there the one on the far left
we're kind of wasting students time
right they weren't struggling with this
to begin with again y-axis is how much
help they need how many errors they're
making
x-axis is opportunities so if they're
not making mistakes to begin with
they've really already mastered that
skill
on the other hand you know the the one
over here a little bit further to the
right
that suggests that the instruction that
we're giving isn't working right they're
not learning anything so
it's not the case that we would give and
that's a little bit misleading in that
point this is a good learning curve for
illustration but there typically aren't
you know 40 questions on one skill
yeah right yeah so it's typically that
problems and activities can be tagged
with multiple skills and so over time as
you interact with different problems
we're still modeling your uh your
mastery of that skill does that help
the thinking is necessarily orthogonal
to this design
where you want to increase the
difficulty of problems as you see
students succeeding
you do that by
adding items that are that have multiple
constructs
at the knowledge component level of
anderson's knowledge component level
um
questions shouldn't differ by difficulty
but not different by a health component
right there's difference in difficulties
i would just be interested in learning
more about the magic of getting the
faculty getting the outcomes and the
skills out of their head and onto a map
we do a somewhat similar process at penn
state at least in my unit working we
call it the blueprinting the course
blueprinting process
it you said it's painful so could you
talk a little bit more about your
strategy for how you do that how long it
takes
and so forth that's a great question
because for the first
six seven years at oli
we didn't have this we were creating
online courses and what we had was
learning scientists who said well you
start with your learning objectives and
as you know you say that to you know
normal faculty member who is wanting to
put their course online i i don't care
about learning objectives i'm trying to
put my course online
you're not following me
what's interesting is once we have had
the the dashboard that norm showed that
became a huge carrot
so
i'm disappointed that we couldn't show
the demo but the ability for an
instructor to pull up this dashboard
before they go into class
that gives the six learning objectives
in the current module that students are
working on and shows as a class you know
for these four they nailed it right i
mean often that's maybe the more rote
information uh for these other two
they're really struggling so now armed
with that information i can go into
class and i don't have to teach
you know the first four i can really
focus on the areas where the students
are struggling which often is the more
you know rich and interesting aspects of
the material anyway
so then we had instructors that we
worked with who who said oh this is
great how do i get that well all you
have to do is define learning objectives
and skills great
so it's i i oversimplify a little bit
it's still as norm said a process but it
is nice to have have there be a more
concrete result maybe than just this is
good good learning design and i think
that as we as analytics get more
sophisticated then i think that that
road becomes easier to walk
and i think the other piece to it really
is this team-based design as well that
um you know that i'm not just handing
off to my faculty uh the course content
and uh big ugly spreadsheet and saying
hey figure this out you know we're
sitting down as a team with multiple
experts and at least one learning
engineer ideally a learning scientist
and working through the process
particularly for our earlier activities
all of which
gives folks this goal at the end of it
to say okay i'm going to get something
useful out of this process i'm not just
doing this to achieve accreditation or
something
i had a question about um over here
the
the intervention you in one of the
slides i think you had a slide about the
interventions that you do
and other than the
the skills that you're trying to get
students to deal with uh how do you
account for things like prerequisites
and prior knowledge or literacy i think
somebody mentioned being able to read
graphs
as one of the
examples of that but also motivation
issues such as time on task or time
between tasks and how you account for
some of those things in in the model
because you may be
as maybe using your graph on the right
there doing the wrong thing over and
over and over again because you're not
looking at some of these other things or
maybe you are i that's really the
question and so the short answer is
badly we account for them badly
i think that we try to be pretty
thoughtful about
questions of motivation prior knowledge
and engagement as we are designing our
learning activities but we don't yet
have a great way to be accounting for
those inside of the dashboard or inside
of the skills map that we've just
demonstrated i think when we're going
back and reviewing the data one of the
things that this can show us is places
where we just have not accounted at all
for prior knowledge because this process
of building a skills map in many ways
implicit in it is some notion of prior
knowledge but it's not something that we
call out explicitly
when we talk about future directions and
this idea of being able to plug in other
models this is part of what we hope to
see it's a richer set of models that can
account for these kinds of factors
you know
as much as we are proud of this work and
proud of uh the output the reality is
that this is still very very early stage
this is the first attempt and there are
lots of pieces of learning that we just
do not account for in this dashboard
as a follow-up to that
ross talked about future directions and
one of the directions that we want to
head in terms of the course design
process is to build in some
interventions around mindset and
belongingness and motivation actually
into the design of the activity so that
we would be able to
have affect detectors i think with ryan
baker we're looking at ways in which we
can build that in to say where
motivation has
decreased and maybe we can provide some
activities uh to students to be able to
moderate that and then in terms of the
prediction models as norm said you know
we have a great start on that but we're
actually hoping to create an analytics
service where we could plug in different
models and tap into researchers who may
be exploring ways in which to do
different kinds of predictions so if
this is something that you're interested
in please feel free to contact us
because we want to be able to make this
open and transparent in terms of the
models that we use how we tune them how
we process them
and
what models might work for different
kinds of students in different
disciplines so maybe something that
works in introductory statistics or
physics might not work in our
introductory psychology or french
courses and so we want to be able to
test different kinds of models in an
open and transparent way sort of with
the theme around open access to data we
want also open access to the way in
which we're analyzing those data
we had some questions up here i think
jackie
so one of the things we've been doing in
california community colleges is
emphasizing learning outcomes versus
learning objectives because the problem
with objectives is like it's 100 percent
as good but 70 is okay
with outcomes you know we found that
students who don't get an a in a
pre-calculus class will never pass the
next course okay a b or c doesn't do it
you have to you have to have the
pre-calc be at the a-level so we ask two
later groups employers and the next
teacher in the sequence
chemistry two
teachers saying they come in not even
knowing what the charge on electron is
uh or employers saying
no they don't know how to buy us a
transistor or things like that so
and unfortunately employers tend to be
very shallow and very near term in
yesterday's problem
but it is another way to look at it not
just the teacher saying ideally out of
my class everybody should learn all this
and my best two students will learn all
this
and the others will do somewhat worse
it's better to have the next teacher
saying this is the minimum i want coming
into this next class
hi this is nafez with the queen running
foundation we're running a version of
open edx in arabic so i'd be very
curious to learn about
sort of your efforts in integrating
the dashboard with open edx and how
that's going on board
and if you guys have ever run any of
this not in english
i mean i understand i i assume that sort
of the interface just need basic
translation and then everything else
could work
uh and if there's a again i've not seen
sort of what the student sees if there's
any part that the student sees i assume
that would also need translation so i
just want to see if you guys have tried
doing that if not if you guys would be
interested in doing that
uh so we do not have the interfaces
fully translated but we are able to we
actually run an arabic language course
on oli that was just released
the last semester within the past six
months and so um
dealing with some of the underlying
coding issues is something that we've
handled but we have not done it on the
on the interface side
in some ways and i hesitate to say it
but in some ways
translating the interface is the easy
piece if you're able to handle this for
the for the learner though
so on the the first in terms of open edx
we've done a gap analysis between that
platform and the oli platform and
you know there's some really great
things about opennet x that we didn't
have in oli one being the the nice
authoring tools
that proven to be very effective
in terms of features that we're looking
to build in uh one important one that
we've been working on is the ability to
deliver hints and targeted feedback
so we put a lot of effort into oli as we
design these questions you know even a
basic multiple choice question
to capture common student misconceptions
that they have often when working
through these problems and represent
those as distractors and then have
feedback that are targeted to those
misconceptions
so just as an example
if you're finding the median of a data
set it turns out that one common student
mistake is to not sort the data just to
pick the middle number without sorting
the data first
and some of the data we collected from
community college study it was about
half as many
as many students made that mistake as
got the question correct and so we
captured that
as a distractor and then wrote feedback
that says ah it looks like you forgot to
order the data first
i have a there's an anecdotal story that
i like which is we had an instructor
watching a student kind of a lab
environment over their shoulder
and i don't think it was that question
but it was another question where the
student made that mistake that so many
students make and got the feedback
targeted toward that mistake
and the instructor overheard the student
say oh my god how'd the computer know
what i was thinking and i love that
because that's right where we want to be
right that's a huge power to this
technology is to be able to fix that in
real time as opposed to you turn in
homework and you know two weeks later
you get it back and there's
so even if there is feedback then you're
not you know you forgot what you were
thinking at that time right
um so that's one of the big pieces that
uh that we were eager to build into the
platform and uh and we're close to being
done with that
uh another is the analytics and that
kind of goes hand in hand so it's these
these questions with this targeted
feedback that we're tagging them with
those skills that are the input to the
uh the analytics model
um and then there's some other those are
kind of the the big ones there's some uh
other features as well that are are kind
of at a next level down i'd be happy to
talk to you more about those but those
are the big ones
um justin right yes nice to see you guys
again um so
you
you have this team who does this you
have team who does skill mapping um and
then i'm curious i guess what fraction
of skill mapping do you decide is done
incorrectly or in completely between
rounds um and what kinds uh you know i
guess what have you learned about the
process of italy how much do you
iteratively revise the skill mapping and
sort of are there any general things
that you've learned about doing like
what kinds of common errors do team make
teams make in skill mapping um what you
know what advice would you give to
people who are starting this from from
having learned from that or what what
what have you published around that or
other sorts of things there yeah great
question that's norm's team
so teams are in love with complexity i
think this is the single biggest issue
that we end up with these remarkably
complicated uh you know three to four
hundred knowledge component
models where you know a single problem
will be tagged with 10 to 12
skills and in reality what this gives
one is
if you're if you really are going to
attempt to model learning at that level
then then 12 points for one question is
is not nearly enough but if what you're
trying to do is provide some uh
pragmatic and actionable information to
either a course improvement team or an
instructor then 12 is probably too many
and so really getting folks to drill in
on this notion of
starting at the outcome level and then
only breaking down as needed
is is something that
i think people need to live through a
few times before they start to
internalize it
so that's the one big piece and the the
other is
it shows up in both the skills mapping
but uh maybe equally importantly in the
kinds of activities that you create um
and it's that expert conflation of
different skills inside of an activity
that i think i'm asking the student to
do one discreet thing but in reality
when you start to unpack it afterwards
you find out that no there are three
different things here and you've just
introduced two of them
which may be okay if you're doing it
consciously but the reality is that
normally we're not doing it consciously
right we're just jumping over and this
is where our expertise lands so i think
those are the two biggest mistakes and
one of them really is a course design
mistake
but we also find is that when this
process is embedded in the learning
activity development phase rather than
being something that we retrofit
it seems to go a little more smoothly
and it has a much more direct impact on
on building a better course or building
a better set of learning experiences
so again just trying to wrap my head
around some of the things you guys are
talking about
is the oli courses set up to be better
for
self-paced courses rather than cohorts
and that is you've mentioned about
targeted
interventions when you know a student
has hit a certain point you
you give them some kind of intervention
or if not how do you account for
groups that are working together what uh
and you know what their
combined skill sets are like just trying
to understand that part the difference
between a very individual assessment
versus
more and more as we see collaborative
learning tools and so forth how do you
deal with those within this model
so one of the original premises from uh
the original instantiation of oali heard
kathy casserly referenced this earlier
today was was a was a research question
can we use these technologies combined
with what we know about learning science
to build a course that can enact
instruction for independent learners so
in 2002 this was what we were trying to
answer
and the way that we approached this was
a very slow and careful design process
what we found pretty quickly was that
yes you can support instruction for
independent learners but those same sets
of materials can effectively support an
instructor in the classroom
much of the work that we've done over
the past 10 years has been bouncing back
and forth between trying to
trying to address both of those
questions and as you point out there are
sometimes very different needs there um
much of the way that we've been
approaching questions of group learning
has been to drill in on specific kinds
of activities uh one example we're
working with uh marlene scardamalia on
um
incorporating knowledge forum as uh as a
set of activities that we could plug
into an oli course currently working
with carolyn rose to do a different set
of collaborative activities
and how those activities plug into our
underlying analytics and how we start to
evaluate and improve those activities
isn't something that we have a perfect
answer for
much of the current set of activities
and the analytics that support them do
assume a significant amount of
independent work on the part of the
student and so we don't have a lot of
group activities on that side
so somewhat related to the question uh
how about peer evaluated questions have
you done that or if you would use this
for
questions where the feedback and grade
comes from appear any new challenges you
foresee
so one challenge there has simply been
compatible data models we've done some
work uh in english composition using the
sword system uh currently chris shoon's
work but i think
panther learning is the company that's
currently owning that and
the learning activities have been
successful but getting those activities
in a separate system to talk back in a
way that we can both capture the data
and plug it into the analytics platform
in real time hasn't been something that
we've hit yet we just haven't had the
resources to devote to it on engineering
side
i assume that's going to continue to be
a challenge um
and you know in many ways moving towards
a world where we're all taking better
advantage of and implementing open apis
for data exchange is going to make that
easier but it's also going to require a
little bit more coalescing around
the underlying data structures that
drive these kinds of skills and
knowledge models i think so sorry as i
say that i feel like i'm copping out
here talking around
we don't have a perfect answer for it
yeah
that's a great question and that's
another big benefit of openedx is some
of these new question types that we
didn't have in oli and so looking at how
we do skills mapping the to questions
like that like the peer grading is a
really interesting new challenge
so i have a question i wanted to ask you
guys
given everything that we've been talking
about how does this fit in your worlds
how do you see this
how and how and if could you imagine
instantiating this in the environments
that you're working in any thoughts on
that
or are we way out there
can i ask a question that actually
builds on that
sure um
looking at faculty particularly at
research one institutions who are
exceptionally busy and maybe have
actually adopted active learning
principles and use classroom assessment
techniques to
get at some of this data
what kind of time on task are you
expecting them to commit to actually be
involved in this skills mapping and some
of the other pieces and
what is the feedback in terms of their
learning about their students and their
teaching
you know that's interesting uh somebody
earlier on i forget who mentioned uh
moocs as sort of this faculty
development proxy was that susan this
morning i think
and in fact it's interesting uh we we've
talked about this um you know fairly
labor-intensive process that we started
off with at oli with the goal being
quality um
but recognizing that that's a very
expensive uh process and so we we have
some uh some experience doing that and
then we've also worked with instructors
in a much less
focused manner we've done some
experiments where we kind of turned the
tools over and and let them you know
kind of just jump in
feet first
and what's interesting is that
there's kind of this transformation that
occurs um
regardless of which scenario we were in
i found which is which is interesting
which is the the act of starting to to
think about putting your content online
and thinking about what kinds of
questions you want to ask really does
tend to start that conversation about uh
what am i trying to get to here and so
what i've heard from
uh faculty instructors across a number
of platforms this isn't limited to oli
by the way
is that
creating their online course really kind
of forced them to think through what
they were trying to accomplish and made
them much better teachers in the
classroom even in just a traditional
classroom that doesn't have anything to
do with online right it really uh
uh
was transformative in that way which is
you know susan said a really exciting uh
possibility here there's another part to
your question
we've already
done this process they've looked at
learning outcomes they've incorporated
backward design
they have you know utilized the
principles of teaching effectively
read how learning works
use classroom assessment techniques to
get data incorporate mastery based
learning you know and so i'm thinking
about the things that you have in your
reports that you've written but what
would be
the point you know like kind of a pain
point essentially if you're looking at
how much time would it take them to
utilize the dashboard some of the other
things that other people have you know
come up with um and what would the
payoff be i mean i'm just thinking about
you know research
faculty right
payoff yep you know great question so
they would have a huge head start so if
you've already thought through a lot of
this then it's it's it's creating the
content in the system and and uh
architecting that uh the payoff is what
the data gives you right that's that's a
huge value to this uh to all the
technologies the data stream that we can
collect about what students are doing
and the kinds of analytics that we've
shown some really i think very you know
early possibilities then i just think
there's so much more that we can do here
and so i think that's the payoff
the kinds of data that they can get from
students working through some of these
environments that you just can't get in
in the classroom environment but which
can be used to
augment and improve the classroom
environment so i think as we've said we
we have courses that
run openly and freely for anybody in the
world to take and people go through them
as independent learners which is kind of
more towards the mooc side of things we
have classes running in a hybrid or
spock version now and and really when
you can combine what online learning is
great at
with the best of in-class learning um
then you know i think we've we've really
got something
so the other payoff
that just seemed like it got louder
bad mic control on is that was that what
it was um
we recently about a year now finished up
the ccoli project community college
initiative
and the evaluation studies that we did
there really tried to drill in on
effectiveness and what we learned were
that the way that faculty use these kind
of tools have a direct impact on how
students engage with these course
materials which in turn has a direct
impact on success in the course and so
in the end this is the other payoff that
this isn't just some exciting
dashboarding tools for them to poke
around on but that there is a direct
impact on student success from all of
this
uh hi um
thank you for a stimulating presentation
i
in response to your question ross um
you know i i teach a statistics course
and this is all very appealing to me and
in some way having a dashboard like this
is like a dream uh
but yet
it feels like what i would need is a
little bit more modularity in being able
to
uh to pick some of the things that
you're doing and adapt to my own course
and the platform that i'm using so right
now
you know i'm using edx uh to teach a
residential course and
saying all right i'm gonna go now to oli
and sort of teach the course from there
seems like a
pretty high uh investment of time going
back to her comments so i think i
if i could give you one answer your
question is just to stimulate what you
said uh earlier which is to to to do it
more openly
so that we can plug in uh some of your
tools and this is this is true for all
online learning it's like why are we
reinventing for each platform what we
could
import i realized technologically this
may be very hard to do but that's from
an instructor's standpoint that that
would be the barrier
uh just a quick response to that so i
agree completely and
some of that may be more possible than
you realize if you're interested in
seeing some examples of how it's worked
i've got a presentation tomorrow talking
about how oli has been used in a mooc
setting and it is possible to plug some
of these pieces directly into or
relatively close to into mooc platform
but but that's the only thing that does
work you're right that you know to
expect the learner or the educator to
start bouncing around between multiple
sites with multiple registrations
not only does not help either party but
in the end also doesn't give any of us
the data that we need to make all of
this work a little more effectively
one last comment about
future directions and where we think
online education is is headed at least
in terms of
some of what we're trying to do with oli
it's not building
complete courses it's this more modular
approach about creating instructional
units that can be adapted modified
remixed reused and so that's one of the
reasons why we looked at openedx is
because the authoring tool so you could
take an introductory module add content
add your own problems
change change
what would meet your particular students
needs that might not be currently
available in the courses right now and
they were built as entire courses and so
i think moving forward we need to think
more about modular approaches to
instruction rather than building online
courses and and that's where we hope to
to take some of what we're doing in the
future
so we don't want to have you miss the
bus so we'll thank you for a great
discussion